foreign
[Music]
and the names of the ancestors the
previously on feels the need to remind
me of Mando falling into an underwater
hole in bogatan doing a belly flop I
kind of feel like all the courage and
skill I'd given them credit for is
actually just a proprietary blend of
best car steel and plot armor
understanding this armor is very tricky
sometimes it does it all and other times
it does nothing and lets water and to
almost drown you you bathed in the
living water cool he did the thing but
I'd really love to know why they're
called The Living Waters and what makes
them so special good thing we have this
whole episode to really dive into the
neat lore I mean it's gonna be really
fun spending this entire episode with
Mando I can't wait can I ask you
something you just did right there that
was your question
I swear that joke was funnier when my
third grade math teacher used it or
maybe that just contributed to my
paranoid nature always expecting gotchas
from everyone I meet did you see
anything alive
alive like what nothing why not just ask
him if he saw the mythosaur den is
obviously religious enough to care about
being re-baptized I don't think he doubt
what you saw or mock you for it there's
absolutely no reason for you to keep
this secret unless you're saving it for
a plot reveal in a later episode and I
swear to Revan if this series ends with
grogu in a tiny Mando helmet wielding
the night saber while
mythial assigned 500 sins or maybe
remove 500 sins I don't know yet but
this is getting at least one sin I would
invite you in for a feast but I'm
guessing that helmet isn't coming off
again and I just realized how limited
mandalorians are during sexy time now
just seems like a depressing cult
especially for the man to lesbians
that sounds just vague enough to cover
the writers for not wanting to show or
Explain the origin of this surprise
attack
never get enough of the Tie Fighter
noise it's so badass this whole sequence
is badass and the show deserves to be
rewarded for giving Daddy what he likes
and yes I'm sorry I will never say that
again are you still up for the transfer
I don't see any other show episode
confirms that these helmets do in fact
obscure your vision
[Applause]
hold on do you need to push a button for
your jetpack or not because when you
leapt into the underground heading to
the mines Mandalore you didn't push any
buttons I don't care how it works just
be consistent
[Music]
was there a reason other than the danger
zone that made Bo Maverick Katan wait so
long to fire up the engines
not a scratch nobody
knocker Mando I bet I bet you're a real
hoot to play Halo with
my home this is a big character moment
for Boca tan who's now lost two homes to
bombings by the Empire and it's all
ruined by the word mud scuffers this is
catastrophic for such a war weary
fighter losing the last shred of home
she had left she's not Leia getting
angry at Han and Chewie for comedic
effect also simply adding another
syllable would have gotten you closer to
the Target mutter scuffers
I agree you should show us where they
all came from so we can get a better
idea of what you're all up against and
why
wait jumping away was an option the
entire time way to render the freaking
cool dog fight scenes completely
pointless if they had jumped away before
leading the Thai interceptors back to
kalavala Beau might still have that big
uncomfortable looking chair
is Mando talking about the viewer
because saving a reveal for the end of
the episode is the only reason to say
this instead of naming the place welcome
to Coruscant the planet of over 1
billion phallic looking buildings we've
got a big rock too but you can't touch
it this is so cool there's so many
possibilities here is grogu gonna get to
explore the ruins of the Jedi Temple
wait where Amanda and Boca tan sadly my
research was twisted into something
cruel inhumane at the behest of a
desperate individual intent on using
honing technology to secure more power
for himself no you do not get to use my
precious Mando to build a rickety
Palpatine Bridge just be Mando Let the
dead speak on their own time
[Music]
Ted Talk at first it sounded like it had
something to do with the amnesty program
the amnesty program saved save life but
now he's talking about his research oh
wait it's about Exposition isn't it
though anything would be comfortable
compared to the outer rim that's outer
remist I've heard exploring the outer
rim can be nice if you're willing to
give it a chance Pershing Empire rebels
new Republic I can't keep track so say
we all wait is this not Battle Star
where am I can this franchise finally
show me how people don't fall out of
these things like all the time or why no
one's hair looks Windswept when they get
to their destination you must be sure to
visit the Sky Dome botanical gardens
chatty Uber drivers just let me stare at
my phone awkwardly in silence until the
ride is over thanks
good evening so when Mando said
someplace they won't find us he wasn't
referring to the Empire but the rest of
the episode itself Armando and grogu
coming back anytime soon this is like
Lane and Jerry bailing on dinner with
Peterman and leaving George stuck in the
meal the writers made us George the top
of this drink seems to magically remove
Itself by the time m34 hands it to Dr
Pershing but I think we're all more
concerned with how unappetizing this
cloudy white liquid looks I bet it's got
a dumb name like Glacier cherry Gatorade
or white Cherry Powerade or semen
uniform did fit better I do miss the
lights of hyperspace episode reminisces
about the good old days for all of the
sometime but it also humanizes the
previously faceless and or voiceless
henchmen that did the Empire's bidding
revealing details about who they are and
what they care about it's refreshing
helps expand the on-screen universe and
I guess it's worth a sent off
trying to sneak this world building
Exposition into the episode like we'd
want to know more about the universe
I'll give the Sci-Fi door points for not
being a whoosh
still super annoying imagine the
cacophony that must engulf this
apartment block every morning during
rush hour I wonder why they're heavy
down here chatty co-workers don't you
have some salmon to heat up in the break
room microwave Brian you know oh the
who still has their job after
programming this Droid to just
haphazardly run into people
so why not continue your research here I
don't think it's something the new
Republic would be interested in if
they're not interested then why do they
have you talking about in front of 50
million people earlier they had Graphics
queued up and everything the
ethics of cloning are complicated yes I
know we had two movies 133 episodes of
Clone Wars in an ongoing series of bad
batch all covering this very topic can
we spend our Mando time covering
something other than cloning please live
a little dog
no but there are still rules right if I
go to the field museum in Chicago and
try to ride sue the T-Rex in an attempt
to mimic my favorite scene from The
Dresden Files and they throw me out that
doesn't make them the Empire are you
experiencing any undue stress do the
work or personal matters interlinked it
would require authorization from the
Department
you could submit a c1023 request but
I've never seen someone from the amnesty
program make one of those Miss friendly
yet contentious interaction coupled with
a doctor being treated like a robot by a
robot in his therapy session shows how
easily the people of this world can get
lost in the bureaucratic process and by
the end of the episode we'll understand
a little more how easy it is for someone
without an anchor to be chewed up by the
machine and or exploited by an
individual ah I think feeling the
tragedy wrapped in this Utopia is going
to squeeze another sin removal out of me
but also squeezing anything out of me is
a sin the lion did say the new Republic
needed help but I don't think Fair
evasion was so complex that the
scientists of Coruscant were still
working the problem Pershing is staring
at people like this is the first time
he's ridden the New York City subway did
he see no other species on the Outer Rim
because I've seen other species on the
outer rim and I don't even live in this
world songs days am I right the writers
make this saying a universal constant
and I hate them for it why are they
being allowed to do it she'll wants me
to believe that a long time ago in a
galaxy far far way they had their own
Mondays am I right but they didn't have
an OSHA an FAA or whomever's
responsibility it would be to prevent
people from falling to their death off
this thing why was this Droid designed
to deal with suspicious passengers by
stalking them as if it were in a horror
movie
really putting those doctoral degree
observational skills to the test ain't
you doc sneaking into a salvage yard on
Coruscant to steal something from a
decommissioned Imperial ship what you're
actually stealing is from this season of
bad batch Omega would be very
disappointed in you John Favreau I must
have passed and ship a hundred times
well they say it's the journey not the
destination we've spent most of the past
10 minutes watching these two walking
and talking in public transportation and
now they're just talking about other
times they were walking in the same
place but not together just saying
sometimes it's not about the journey
either
what you mean she was gonna betray him
all along this changes everything how
will the Star Wars Universe go forward
from
uh
this is a mind flare this is a 602
mitigator A Rose by Any Other Name
cliche you'll see some pleasant colors
you're a light buzzing and experience a
great sense of relief in no time at all
if that's your goal why not just give
him some weed you basically just
described every afternoon right before I
record this narration
um I mean when I get done recording this
narration
[Music]
it's nice to know that for every failure
is a success like you I don't think this
character could Telegraph any harder
that Elias some kind of double agent or
spy the writers might as well have had
her eat one of those travel biscuits
if this device is just meant for healing
now and it's only used for low voltages
why even leave the option for it to go
to 11. to a Mandalorian covert oh
they finally remembered who the main
character was this was a very strange
episode of the mandoland Orion it will
go smoother if you keep your helmet on
trust me the entirety of my father's
birds and the bees talk somehow makes it
into the episode oh boy I'm glad we're
back to the main story so we can now
watch mandalorians do some walking well
everyone has to walk sometimes can't all
be rocket packs Space Battles and
Blaster fights it's an important and
necessary oh for the love of grogu come
on guys this episode had so many cool
things in it it could have been a
contender it could have been somebody
instead of a bum which is what it is
let's face it these are indeed The
Living Waters all that walking just to
watch the armorer test the pH balance of
some water
just
really unappetizing to look at
foreign
[Music]
that's what your mom said last night
you want to touch it are we allowed to
oh is this your first time do you still
find your current housing situation
comfortable
gingering claims to have bathed in the
Living Waters is this true one time not
happened welcome Bo Katan of Clan Cree
this is the way this is the way
[Applause]
[Music]